Okay, then the last thing is PSRs,
or Predictive State Representation.
>> Yes, indeed and
the upshot of the PSR idea was what?
>> Well, that rather than thinking about
states which might not even exist, and
even if they do exist you never
know where you're in them or not,
so really they don't exist in some very
important insane potato sort of way.
What does make sense to think about is
whether there are specific tests that
you could take that would then predict
what you are likely to observe.
And that in some sense that's a very
satisfying way of thinking about
the world that I need to
kind of keep track of and
well if I were to do certain
things now what would happen and
that was kind of the push for
sort of PSRs.
And in so far as you prefer that kind
of way of thinking about the world,
the nice thing is that PSRs
can represent any POMDP, and
so they're equivalent.
>> Right, except maybe more palatable
philosophically or so forth.
Certainly Rich Sutton was pushing
people in the direction of this
representation for that reason.
There's a kind of philosophical
stance that says.
Am I sick?
What does it mean to be sick?
It means that I [LAUGH]
could be dead tomorrow,
I could be stuck in bed tomorrow,
I could be running a fever.
It's like there's a bunch of observable
things that are a function of
what the current state is, and so
it might be useful to talk about things
in terms of what those predictions
are as opposed to positing some
kind of magical internal state.
>> Well, this makes sense right
because the only usefulness.
If you go back to that and we talked
about this on our lesson management
course in some sense the only
usefulness of a state is what it allows
you to predict about what's going to
happen next, little made of objects.
So, the only reason it's worthwhile
even recognizing something as a state
is it allows me to distinguish
between something else that might be
important later.
So right, so another one of our
universal contradictory truths is that
states and
predictors are kind of the same thing.
>> Yeah, all things are the same.
>> Excellent, all right,
so I think that's the last lesson
that I was doing by myself.
I think I'm going to turn it
over to you for the next one.
>> Well, I will point out that
you none of this by yourself like
we've done this together.
>> That's fair.
>> Alright, well with that I
guess we should say goodbye.
>> Alright, see you next time.
>> Bye.
[LAUGH]